hey 42 here the early 90s gave us the
spice girls
friends and minesweeper in 1992
microsoft released windows 3.1 and they
packaged it with two games that would go
on to
cost companies all over the world
billions of dollars in lost
worker productivity solita added to
windows in 1990
and minesweeper added in 1992
you may assume that microsoft went to
the trouble of coding
and releasing these free games to
provide windows users with
endless hours of procrastination-filled
fun
but you'd be wrong they actually
concealed a secret
agenda microsoft added these games to
windows to
teach the world how to use a mouse
as the 80s rolled over into the 90s
computer mice were
only now beginning to attract widespread
consumer adoption
even though the computer mass was
invented by douglas engelbart
in 1964 in the 70s and early 80s
most people were accustomed to
controlling their home computers
solely using the keyboard nowadays we
grow up with computer
mice so the neural circuitry required to
develop the
innate motor neuron control for
efficient mouse usage
is formed at such a young age and so
for young people it never feels like
they had to learn
how to use a mouse the brain is much
more
plastic meaning moldable in our youth
so it's far easier to pick up new skills
that's why you were able to frag noobs
with your sweet flick shots
by the time you were 15. but when you
present a middle-aged man with a
computer mouse who has
never used one before he looks at it
like you've just asked him to launch a
nuclear missile with a sandwich
the older the brain gets the more
difficult it becomes to learn
what young people assume is really basic
stuff
moving the mouse around a desk to
control a virtual
environment that's why your grandma
probably takes much
better to a tablet than a desktop
computer
pointing out and pressing buttons is a
natural movement
that she's probably done many times
before but a mouse
is completely alien to her microsoft
knew this so they designed solitaire to
teach
people how to use a mouse to
drag and drop what do you do when you
play solitaire
you spend hours dragging and dropping
cards
dragging and dropping minesweeper on the
other hand was designed to teach people
how to click
but more importantly the difference
between left and right
mouse clicks get the left and right
mouse buttons confused in mindsweeper
and you'll be virtual toast so it's a
fantastic
training tool negative reinforcement
worked for minesweeper if you blew
yourself up you would adjust your
strategy so the next time
you didn't but we're often told that the
best training tool
is actually positive reinforcement
rather than negative
the carrot is better than the stick
praise is more effective
than punishment but how true
is this at the end of this video i'll
reveal
how israeli fighter pilots disproved
the common adage that praise is better
than punishment
in a dutch neuroscience study eight to
12 year
olds were asked to solve puzzles on a
computer half of the children were shown
a green tick
on screen when they answered correctly
but no symbol
when they didn't the other 50 of
children were shown a red cross when
they answered incorrectly
but no tick when they answered correctly
the tasks were then repeated
over and over again to measure how the
children improved at the puzzles
over time as various tv super nannies
keep telling us reward wins out
over punishment and this experiment
reflected that
the group of children that were shown
positive reinforcement for correct
answers
the green tick showed a substantial
improvement with the accuracy
and speed of their answers over the
course of the experiment
but the other children who were punished
for incorrect answers
well they showed absolutely no
improvement if anything they got worse
at the puzzles
the more they repeated them so there we
go that definitively answers this
question
and we can all go to sleep peacefully
tonight except
there's an enormous elephant-shaped
caveat
lurking in the corner of the room you
see the dutch neuroscientists decided to
repeat the exact same experiment
with a group of older participants more
specifically
young adults aged 18 to 25.
the results for this group were the
polar opposite
of the children's the young adults
showed much greater improvement
when they were punished with crosses and
almost no improvement when they were
rewarded with ticks
something changes drastically in the
brain between being a child
and an adult and since after the age of
21 our brain becomes
less plastic and is thus more set in its
ways
it could be assumed that if the
experiment was repeated with any age
group older than 25
then punishment would always win out
over reward
for improving learning and behavior to
further
prove the point that this change is the
result of a fundamental alteration
in the construction of the brain as we
age the dutch neuroscientists took brain
scans of the children 8 to 12
whilst completing the tasks what they
discovered
was that the learning centers of the
brain specifically the cerebral cortex
activated much more strongly in the
group that received
reward than the punishment group
yet with the 18 to 25 year olds it was
reversed
their brains activated more strongly
when punished
for their mistakes the experimenters
concluded
that this is because it's more difficult
to process
negative reinforcement than positive
children
respond better to and learn easier from
reward because
it's a really simple concept to grasp
in the words of the author of the paper
learning from mistakes is more complex
than carrying on in the same way as
before
you have to ask yourself what precisely
went wrong
and how it was possible we only learn
the ability
to effectively learn from our mistakes
as we
mature into young adults and our brains
become fully developed
but there's a fundamental rule that
explains
why punishment is more effective than
reward
and why neither punishment or reward
have very little effect
on an outcome at all it's called
regression to the mean and it was
famously demonstrated in the 1960s
when daniel kahneman an israeli
psychology professor
made a landmark discovery whilst
lecturing to a class
of air force fighter pilot instructors
in tel aviv
kahneman was driving home the point to
the instructors that rewarding good
behavior or performance
will improve the capability and learning
speed of the students
whilst punishing bad behavior will
reduce morale and
not improve learning he was espousing
the virtues
of the carrot over the stick before he
could finish his speech one of the
instructors loudly interjected
with respect sir what you're saying is
literally for the birds
i've screamed at people for badly
executed maneuvers and
by and large the next time they improve
he followed up with
i've often praised people warmly for
beautifully executed maneuvers
and next time they almost always do
worse
don't tell me that reward works and
punishment doesn't
my experience contradicts it furthermore
the entire audience of instructors
resoundingly
agreed with him that punishment is a
more effective teaching tool
than praise kahneman decided to
investigate further to see if he could
definitively quantify whether perhaps
he had been wrong all this time and the
instructors
were right after observing the flight
instructors for some time and collecting
further data
conneman uncovered a rather surprising
truth
the flight instructor's shouting always
preceded
the improvement of the student receiving
said bollocking but it didn't actually
cause it because the student would
always improve after messing up
regardless of
whether or not he was reprimanded
kahneman put his findings down to a
phenomenon
called regression towards the mean
this is the universal axiom that in any
series of random events there will
always be
periods of variation peaks and troughs
but over time the results will always
regress towards the mean if i roll a
six-sided die
over and over again i may occasionally
get lucky and hit
three sixes in a row but over enough
iterations
my average roll is always going to
settle at 3.5
because that is the mean of a six-sided
die
and the law of large numbers dictates
that any series of random events
must always regress towards the mean
to translate this logic to fighter
pilots the students
all have their own mean level of
performance
their mean will increase slowly over
time
sure with enough practice but increasing
that skill
takes thousands of hours and so in the
very
short term the performance of their
day-to-day flights are going to
vary in a seemingly random manner many
factors can increase takeoff
flight and landing performance on any
given day
wind conditions temperatures tire
pressure how much sleep the pilot had
last night and so on
if the pilot happens to do better or
worse than usual
then that is straying away from their
mean
performance so statistically the
following time out they are
almost always going to regress
towards their mean that means if they
performed worse than usual last time
they will most likely do better next
time out
and if they did better than usual then
they will probably do worse next time
so when the instructors shouted at the
students for poor performance and they
improved next time out
it was because of regression to the mean
and had very little to do
with the instructor's course language
but from the instructor's point of view
it would seem that their
bollockings made the students perform
better
but in reality it actually had very
little impact on their future
performance
the students performed better mostly
because of chance
and when the instructors praised their
students for good performance
because the performance that incited
that praise was better than their
average performance
they would because of chance do worse
next time out so the instructors walked
away with
the false assumption that their praise
actually
reduced the performance of their
students
i'm not saying that praising good
behavior is useless
no it does actually have a small impact
however it has much much less of an
impact on future behavior than what we
are usually
led to believe having said that there
are of course many instances in life
when a little praise can go a long way
for instance
not praising your girlfriend for cooking
you a lovely dinner after she spends the
day working nine to five
is a sure-fire way to receive a world of
pain
thanks for watching i've recently
launched my first book which i'm
crowdfunding through unbound publishing
it's called sticker flag in it a
thousand years of bizarre history
from britain and beyond if you'd like to
get your hands on a first edition
signed copy then please head on over to
unbound the links in the description
and pledge today thank you